no
a cuántos de ustedes les gusta el mundo
tal y como es
levanten la mano por favor
algunas personas levantaron la mano pero
fueron realmente pocas la respuesta a
esta pregunta realmente parece sencilla
porque todos podemos encontrar algún
aspecto de la realidad social que nos
preocupa nos incomoda o nos molesta
seguramente algunos de ustedes no
levantaron la mano no dijeron que el
mundo les gusta tal y como es porque
pensaron en situaciones de pobreza de
violencia en muchas injusticias y muchas
violaciones de derechos humanos que
suceden cotidianamente algunas de ellas
nos afectan directamente algunas de
ellas sólo las percibimos a través de
los medios de comunicación o sabemos que
suceden más o menos lejos de nosotros
también algunos de ustedes pudieron
haber pensar en situaciones relativas al
deterioro ambiental que estamos viviendo
al cambio climático al calentamiento
global a la escasez de agua a las 3 o 5
especies que se existe que se extinguen
cada hora en todo el planeta
y frente a estas realidades
nosotros estamos continuamente expuestos
a muchísima información
yo les vengo a compartir hoy un poco de
lo que ha aprendido a través de los ya
casi 15 años que llevo trabajando en
materia de promoción y defensa de
derechos de niños niñas y adolescentes
y comencé a trabajar este tema pues hace
ya mucho tiempo comencé haciendo
investigación desarrollando mis tesis de
grado y aquí les comparto algunas de las
cifras que a mí más me conmueven no
depronto viendo esta esta realidad por
ejemplo en 2006 la organización de las
naciones unidas publicó un estudio
mundial sobre violencia y niñez y en ese
estudio se reveló que había 265 millones
de niños y niñas y adolescentes
alrededor de todo el planeta enfrentando
alguna forma grave de violencia algo más
alarmante aún fue que este estudio
reveló que el lugar más inseguro para
niños y niñas es su hogar que mucha de
esta violencia sucede en el ámbito de lo
familiar en el ámbito doméstico
un estudio más reciente de la unicef
sobre esta misma materia se dio a la
tarea de investigar cuáles eran las
diferentes formas de violencia que
experimentan los niños y niñas a lo
largo de diferentes segmentos de edad
allí se detectó que el abuso sexual es
la forma de violencia más corrientemente
experimentada por niños y niñas desde
los 0 hasta los 17 años esto quiere
decir que hay incluso bebés que están
sufriendo abuso sexual
y bueno ya la semana pasada el
secretariado ejecutivo del sistema
nacional de seguridad pública dio a
conocer que en mexico de 2016 a 2019 se
tiene registro de 280 feminicidios de
niñas y adolescentes
entonces estas cifras y nosotros nos
detenemos a intentar visualizar no lo
que significa lo que hay detrás de estos
números pues nos enfrentamos a un
panorama realmente sobrecogedor no
porque al final lo que estas cifras nos
están diciendo es que existen personas
adultas que utilizan su fuerza y su
posición para abusar de adolescentes
niños y niñas algunos de ellos muy
pequeños en una estructura social y
cultural que permite este abuso y que a
veces no sólo lo permite sino que lo
facilita
entonces eso yo no sé a ustedes pero a
mí me pone los pelos de punta no a mí es
una realidad que me enoja mucho y que me
causa mucha tristeza y así cada uno de
ustedes cada una de ustedes seguramente
tendrá aspectos de la realidad social
que le generen emociones diversas y
emociones fuertes de acuerdo a su
experiencia y a su historia de vida muy
personal
entonces frente a todas estas cosas que
sabemos no en promedio se calcula que
los mexicanos pasamos al día 7 horas con
14 minutos conectados a internet
y esta es una gran exposición no a
grandes flujos de información y lo
interesante es que hacemos cada uno de
nosotros y nosotras con esa información
con esos datos que tenemos muchos de
nosotros somos consumidores compulsivos
de información es decir todos estos
casos y cifras pues son como superfluas
porque solamente las admitimos y las
desechamos de inmediato no se conectan
con nuestra práctica es probable que
generen algún tipo de reacción no que
nos causen una ira fugaz o que nos
pongamos tristes momentáneamente o
quizás que andemos con miedo y que
tomemos algunas tipo de precaución pero
pocas veces se conectan con una práctica
colectiva y transformadora
entonces nuestro reto pues es
convertirnos más bien en consumidores
responsables de información de la misma
manera en que es necesario que nos
volvamos consumidores responsables de
bienes y servicios
es necesario que hagamos de la
información con la que contamos un uso
más crítico un uso más consciente pero
sobre todo
conectemos todos esos datos con nuestra
práctica concreta con una práctica
transformadora
y esta práctica transformadora no se va
a poder presentar en ningún otro lugar
que no sea nuestro ámbito de acción
cotidiano nuestro entorno más inmediato
esa práctica transformadora no la vamos
a poder ejercer en otro sitio que no sea
la escuela la que vamos el vecindario en
donde estamos la ciudad en la que
vivimos
o la familia o los amigos con los que
compartimos día con día
y lo que nos va a permitir conectar
estos saberes globales toda esta
información que tenemos con acciones
locales sobre todo a nosotros no a
nosotros que podemos tomarnos el tiempo
para hacer un alto y reflexionar sobre
estos temas porque hay que reconocer que
sobre todo en un país como méxico
acceder a la educación acceder a la
información acceder al tiempo libre
todavía son privilegios pero aquellos de
nosotros que tenemos acceso a todos
estos bienes
tenemos que convertirlos en prácticas
concretas
y lo que nos va a permitir o lo que yo
he visto que es necesario para poder
hacer esa conexión
la imaginación no
nosotros tenemos que poder ser capaces
de situarnos frente a la realidad y
poder construir en nuestra mente un
escenario diferente al que estamos
viviendo yo en mis salones de clases
algunas veces he escuchado estudiantes
que cuando discutimos temas como los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible la
corrupción la violencia el cambio
climático manifiesta en una postura muy
escéptica al cambio que dicen bueno
estas cosas ya son procesos como
irreversibles porque están anclados en
la estructura de la sociedad entonces es
muy difícil que la que la sociedad
cambie
cuando yo oigo este tipo de postura me
siento muy sorprendida porque en
realidad el mundo cambia constantemente
no todo el tiempo están ocurriendo
cambios si yo hago un ejercicio de
memoria y me pongo a recordar cómo eran
por ejemplo mis clases en la
licenciatura yo puedo ver no recordar
que tenía maestras que fumaban mientras
daban su clase
y esto era posible claro porque no había
regulación sobre el consumo de tabaco en
espacios públicos quiere decir que no
había que la gente todavía no se
movilizaba para llegar a ese este
momento no en el que ya fumar en un
espacio público es una cosa pues
impensable
entonces el mundo cambia constantemente
y lo que hay que hacer es imaginarnos
imaginarnos el mundo que sí nos guste el
mundo en el que si queremos vivir
dice diane di prima una poeta de la
generación beat que la única guerra que
importa es la guerra contra la
imaginación de todas las otras guerras
están subsumidas en esta guerra y yo
estoy de acuerdo con eso no porque creo
que en el momento en el que nosotros
pensamos que las cosas que son de una
manera no pueden ser distintas entonces
ya tenemos la batalla perdida
y para hacer crecer nuestra imaginación
para que florezca nuestra imaginación y
poder generar cambios sociales lo que
tenemos que hacer es construir vínculos
no relacionarnos con personas y sobre
todo empezar a actuar
en este camino d
y tratar de frenar no de estar
preocupada por la violencia que afecta a
niños niñas y adolescentes pues yo he
desarrollado acciones muy diversas como
les decía desde que estaba estudiando la
licenciatura pues me involucre en una
encuesta nacional sobre trabajo infantil
callejero y después desarrollé
investigaciones y tesis de grado sobre
las mismas problemáticas o problemas
relacionados después trabajé
directamente en una asociación civil que
atienden niños y familias afectados por
violencia y pobreza actualmente y tengo
una red una alianza de mujeres que
trabajamos en diferentes países no para
difundir y capacitar a personas adultos
responsables del cuidado de niños y
niñas pero bueno también he tenido un
blog personal donde escribo artículos no
académicos escrito incluso cuentos no
osea ficciones que tratan de abordar el
tema y en este camino pues he conocido
proyectos y personas maravillosas que
están preocupadas por lo mismo que son
ingenieros que son artistas
proyectos que trabajan aquí en la ciudad
en el estado en el país y gente que está
trabajando también en gran bretaña en
chile no en muchos lugares entonces creo
que eso es lo maravilloso de convencerte
de que hay algo que quieres cambiar que
en cuanto tú empiezas a hacer algo vas a
identificar otras personas instituciones
proyectos gente que ya está trabajando
en lo mismo bueno con una mirada que es
a lo mejor distinta de la que tú tienes
entonces esto es una fuente de un
aprendizaje que te enriquece de manera
personal
muchísimo entonces si hay muchas piedras
en el camino pero también hay muchas
cosas que sí se pueden hacer y creo que
el reto aquí es establecer estos
vínculos estas articulaciones porque hay
ideas padrísimas que no pueden florecer
porque carecen de los vínculos
necesarios
entonces la invitación aquí es pensar la
realidad como nuestro trampolín no como
nuestra jaula
pensar que podemos dar un salto para
acercarnos a ese mundo en donde en donde
pensamos aquí si me gusta vivir la
mayoría de las cosas que pasan aquí si
están acordes a lo que yo deseo no a un
mundo que sea más digno y más libre para
todas las personas entonces creo que es
muy bueno preocuparnos porque hay una
isla de basura flotando en el océano
pacífico que es del tamaño de texas pero
también sería muy bueno organizarnos con
nuestros familiares y con nuestros
vecinos para reducir nuestro consumo y
generar menos desechos
o es muy bueno con dolernos porque hay
niños en la india que realizan trabajo
esclavo
pero también es muy bueno ver en nuestra
comunidad qué es lo que están haciendo
las autoridades para frenar o disminuir
el trabajo infantil aquí en nuestra
ciudad en nuestro estado o identificar
qué organizaciones civiles están
trabajando en eso y ofrecernos como
voluntarios
o colaborar de alguna manera porque cada
uno de ustedes y cada una de ustedes
tiene talentos y tiene energía y tiene
habilidades que son muy necesarios y muy
valiosos para transformar la sociedad
entonces hay que dar ese salto hay que
ver la realidad como trampolín y sobre
todo pensar que ese salto no lo tenemos
que dar solos no es un salto que hay que
dar en grupo y en comunidad porque si
queremos avanzar solos
vamos a tener un gran desgaste y
seguramente muy pocos resultados
mientras que si empleamos la realidad
como un trampolín colectivo es entonces
cuando vamos a identificar todo lo que
ya está sucediendo y eso va a hacer
crecer no sólo nuestras esperanzas
sino nuestra certeza de que el mundo
puede cambiar hacia como nosotros
queremos que sea muchas gracias
[Aplausos]